and you're watching Game of Thrones I am
I think the seasons been pretty great so
far yeah I think great but I do have
some issues with how much they diverged
from the books did you read the books no
I didn't read the book okay well okay in
the books they set up a bunch of stuff
with the Lord of the light and the
prophecy about the prince who was
promised which was supposed to be the
second coming of a Zora hi but in the TV
show Arya is the one who becomes the
hero and yet when you look at the books
the important thing to remember is that
they have a habit oh my god I had to get
out of there I can't stand listening to
someone complain about how something's
better in the books
oh I'm sorry the nonstop action on the
screen didn't live up to your standards
of Dork them some people can't enjoy
anything well I better get back what I'm
saying is now that Melisandre is dead
I'm worried it's never gonna pay off
because in the books it's just the way
they don't work a but you know sometimes
we have to let things go I mean it's
like my therapist was saying the other
day you can't control events you can
only control your own reaction which is
white you know just 45 minutes of
meditation per day and it doesn't even
have to be in one chump man once you get
Andy started on stuff he learned in
therapy
he won't stop - were all crying in the
fetal position oh I guess that sky still
going has he gotten to the part about
his attachment theories yet wait a
second you don't like Andy's therapy
talk either
look if he knows so much about therapy
then why isn't it working right well at
least he's not like this guy bad hot sex
scene had factual inconsistencies
yeah we both have to put up with a lot
of [ __ ] some days I just blocked
this douche out and pretend we're not
even the same person you know that's
actually called compartmentalization my
therapist calls me out on it and and I'm
sorry I got to call you out on it too
see now you're talking about your
therapist - why are you so resistant to
therapy I mean maybe you should explore
that oh I'm sorry I'm so sorry you
scared me for a second there yeah I just
have to go even deeper into my
subconscious to get past it you should
try it deeper into myself conscious I
don't know if that's a good idea
oh come on let's see who's in there all
right fine hello who are you
I'm calling super-ego are you surprised
at this iron deficient husk of a body
could house up in this sexy
yeah actually you're my favorite Conan
yet well why don't we get out of here
and go grab a drink no okay
hey guys can I come too no way
hell no let's go Andy
[Applause]